hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to weekly update number two
alright so I'm out of town again it's
Sunday today it's like the sixth
actually my dad's birthday today and so
dice were out of town so if you check
out like the view here it's it's just
really nice I mean look at this gold
before in Daylesford right now been
quite a week this week actually both to
me and probably for you guys as well I
mean it was new here he has just started
2013 this year like I'm really excited
about this year personally just because
not only on YouTube but also like in my
life I mean I'm starting universities
probably I haven't actually gotten into
anything yet because i think the office
comments also like I guess my urine
couch if it was a really big things
planned and I'm they really have
anything to do with this channel but I'm
I've been working with other companies
as well and we're really I'm really
bringing something forward and I've been
actually talking about a project
probably sends about November last year
remember 2012 and I've never actually
unveiled what that project is and I know
a lot of you guys have been just
tweeting me asking me every time live
streaming you're like what's this
project about dude you gotta tell me and
I've sort of been keeping it on the
down-low robot as far as like it has
nothing to do with gate with programming
alright so don't worry about like you
can just just put that away because I'm
it's yeah you can rest in peace paces
like resting paces on you know you can
just you can just peacefully say alright
just doesn't concern me but it is an
entertainment thing it's actually a sure
that I've been working on with the
company on
actually so that that that's really all
that's really exciting and you know I've
just been finishing up a trailer and you
know that'll that'll go on soon but um
I'll definitely keep you guys updated
with that because it's love because it's
damn exciting in my opinion but other
than that you know game programming
return we had um I think episode 43
would have gone up like thursday night
friday sorry friday um 44 on saturday
and its daily now yeah yeah i mean game
program is back to being daily with the
exception of sunday's for sunday's
weekly update day but you know apart
from that um yeah you guys should
probably be really happy about that i'm
happy to be back for that is it's been
quite a while and i've actually got some
other things planned for this channel
like subtle thing so i was not as big as
that being a big project but um there's
still some pretty pretty exciting stuff
for you guys to play around with with
sha which I'll talk about in a minute
but um the other thing I wanted to
mention and yeah I'm in Daylesford I
think I mentioned that earlier in the
video but um this is Dale's for so
basically this place has like these
mineral springs and they're pretty like
they're pretty good it's mineral water
and my parents like my parents we
usually made my parents usually come
here like once a year or so just to like
grab grab a bunch of bottles and
literally bring back like a hundred
liters of this water there's different
like types of Springs here and yeah then
Saul free as well so that's what I'm
doing here but um yeah but from that the
other thing I wanted to talk about was
ah the minecraft server so last week we
felt at one I told you guys about this
feed the best minecraft server that I
was doing and a few of you might have
noticed has been down for a while and
I'm actually like I'm really in peace
with that as well because it keeps going
down it keeps crashing and I'm trying
I'm really trying to fix that right now
I'm working with both you know the
company that was working with those
people coming out ways and keep moving
down this bridge I've been working with
multiplay who are the people um
who actually hosted and stuff like that
and as far as I can tell like from
reading crash reports it's an ftp thing
it's FTB is like crushing with like a
nullpointerexception or something so I'm
you know a nullpointerexception crash
immediately tells me that that's just
bad programming so something is wrong in
that pack I mean if it was something
like an out of memory exception then
well yeah fair enough if you go ahead
and crash if you encounter that but um
ya know it's just been crashing due to
um you know what seems like an old
pointer exception so I'm that's
obviously out of my control it hasn't
legit with the server but I'm gonna want
to play around with us if see if we can
get that working a video also went up on
how to join that server because I'm a
lot of people were asking a lot of
people kept telling me that like my
server was down when it was it down that
was before it actually started going
down by the way um and also a lot of
people were was sort of gone like you
know how do I join your server to the
service out of data access rights are
actually made a video on my gaming
channel on the message oh no journal on
how to actually get to the server so
I'll link that video below but other
than that you know that's that's a deal
with the server I'm still trying to fix
it so as soon as I do I'll let you guys
know but so far you guys have been
really supportive and a thank you for
that I thank you for your patience but
yet but you know I've got the level file
backed up the level files already over a
gig so yeah I mean it's like one point
zero two gigabytes or something so I'm
yeah you guys going crazy on that but
you know apart from that that's just
that's just how that rolls finally I
also wanted I've actually I tweeted out
again and I'll probably ask so many
questions in a minute but um the other
thing I wanted you guys to do is for
future weekly updates I mean because
eventually I'm gonna stop being out of
town and there'll be nothing to talk
about probably maybe maybe maybe not but
probably so if you guys could like leave
a topic that you want me to talk about
and like a good like five minutes worth
of talk not like a half hour discussion
or you know song of that but like a good
like five to ten minute maybe discussion
talk about it then I'm you live a
comment below with what you want me to
talk about and and guys if you something
if you see something that you like just
like thumbs up that comment and then
I'll do the one that gets the most likes
i'll do i'll talk about what gets the
most likes alright so we have a comment
below right now let me know what you
we want to talk about but um but yeah
one other thing that I really wanted to
touch like really gently on was um I've
been started doing these live streams
where I am where I'm sort of like
working on developing the cherno engine
which is like this 2d game engine that
I've been working on just for a while
just like a framework to give you guys
to play around with as well so that I'm
so that in the future maybe after I
finished the game programming series so
that I don't have to do a series i can
just show you guys one thing and you
know you won't have to type out like two
thousand lines of code you'll be able to
download the engine and then use it to
do this one one technique or something
so that i can i can sort of give you
guys like singular singular videos i
guess that aren't really in a series so
like tip some of that so those live
streams have been going on i know a lot
of you guys really like them I don't
have time to do them all the time so I
can't do them like every night
unfortunately I love to but you know
sort of high price on time but um I do
them when I can and it's awesome to see
a lot of you a lot of you guys like them
they'll always be available for video
on-demand viewing so if you miss a
stream or you're in like Germany because
i know i know that streams the people on
the bridge I know that streams like this
dreams are like blocked in Germany
because Germany thinks is it's like a
like a television thing and you have to
pay for it I don't know I've been to
Germany several times so yeah I know
it's a bit of a they've got interesting
laws there about television for instance
you actually have to pay money to have a
television in your house so like there's
no such thing as freely wet free TV if
you've got a TV in your house and you're
not paying for it like I'm gonna get a
pretty big fine but yeah so like it's
really important to I don't know they've
got interesting lols like that guess
that country do whatever there is
something called rock star um anyway so
um questions on Twitter I'm not gonna
lie cancer too many because I really
have to go it's like 2pm known I've
already had lunch but I needed like
drive home but one thing I wanted to
mention yeah [ __ ] remove no off my
head Colin won the keeps coming up I
didn't even check Twitter job I don't
know I check like one tweet on Twitter I
think um
but a common question when did when did
I start programming that's an easy
question ourselves go right now I
started programming when I was about 12
so that's a lie actually probably at
eleven I started developing games when I
was twelve actually into the game
competition when I was 12 so that would
have been like six years ago so that's
that question answered i guess but i
think programming like desktop
programming like application 11 11 10 to
11 maybe and game actually game
development 12 i'm at a game i finished
again when i was 12 years old which I
was pretty proud of but yeah I think in
place like so I was like runner-up to a
game like a game competition as well but
yeah I used to get me so I guess we
really counts program and your thing is
was my favorite thing that I made in
Java oh that I've programmed ever really
weird actually work out became nailing
chicks producing offspring I'll steal
scoring phrases that's like that's just
that's just so go that's just such a
perfect game I love that game I might
actually like bring out some updates for
it honestly because i'm bored and it's
just something like an easy finger all
right to other things that i wanted to
quickly mention first of all like i get
countless messages today being like you
know help me out with their so on a
programming help or you know episode
like 42 or 41 or something a pretty game
programming even you know I did this
strong you know my get my co doesn't
work help me out like guys as much as I
love you like there is no way that I can
get around to helping that volume of
people like I actually have stuff to do
which you know I'm trying to say this
and looking the nicest way possible with
guys like come on like I can't help out
eight and a half thousand people like
that's insane I'm off speaking that
thanks 48.6 I guess I'll be on a place
xk by the time I get home because I was
on like what 20 away when I am
but um yeah thanks for eight thousand
six hundred subscribers rocking up soon
we'll be over 9000 sorry excited for
that but yeah like guys if you need help
with your code right now coming to me is
probably probably not even gonna answer
because it's just it's risk becoming
ridiculous like a year ago was fine
we'll have been doing this here a year
ago I'm starting this year ago like half
a year ago this was fine but like I
can't take it anymore especially when
it's the same problem so I'm gonna be
I'm not gonna be like you know while I
really can't provide you with support
and usually it's not a case of something
not working that I didn't explain it
just a case of you taking down the code
on the video like not not correctly and
the solution is virtually re-watched the
video but because of that I have I have
a subreddit alright and i made this
subreddit pretty much specifically for
this if you actually go to our stash the
turner and you'll see the link in the
description it's in it's in the
description of every video that is where
you post your problem because i
guarantee to you within like a few hours
someone will reply someone will tell you
i'm like washing out for like friggin
snakes and other animals here because
freaking dangerous place here she's
trailing Outbacks only the app but I'm
anyway post up on reddit on my subreddit
on reddit com / r / the show no and I
guarantee to you you will someone will
help you out let's get stuck in the
moderation queue I really sure that I
keep forgetting but um just post the
post there and what should happen is
someone someone will help you out push
code they're both crashing there and you
can guess you'll get some support
alright that's the other that's out roll
so that's the best way to actually get
help finally want to close off the same
[ __ ] ray 3 is a very good game last week
but I forgot far cry 3 you guys are like
I don't know if you guys want to buy a
game by far cry 3 yes it's amazing it's
like it's like crisis and
I together but I think it's more fun and
scarf scarves normal content technically
bit like Skyrim definitely you don't get
attached to the characters in scar you
do in Far Cry 3 library like it's it's
like movie quality it's very good the
writing the story lines just epic so I'm
fuel confirm game you get back or I
three and no i did not get paid to say
this alright so that's going to wrap up
update number two weekly update number
two and yeah if you like the video
please hit like please hit a like please
hit the like button below and leave a
comment on what women talk about and you
know if you your comment gets the most
likes then I'll talk about that in the
next video in the next weekly update
will help their number three which will
probably be in town not our town but
these two have been downtown which is
pretty cool until then you guys lay it
up turn her out
you